[Music]  in five days  you're wondering what happens now  the illuminati will see you stephen  all right something  the multiverse  will change you forever  we will see what kind of doctor strange  you are  marvel studios doctor strange jdpg seed  premium large formats and imax only  theatre's friday  stephen strange  the illuminati will see you now  we will see what kind of dr strange you  are marvel studios doctor strange 13.  the multiverse it's dangerous  i could use an avenger  it's about time you showed up  on may 6th  enter a world  of strange try not to break the  multiverse stephen  oh come on  dr strange in the multiverse of madness  video pg-13 you can see it in premium  large format in imax tickets on sale now  [Music]  you